but has the film group as a
feature-length instead of a short how
did these interviews come into play
you're contacting people across the
country or they're contacting you that
own tiny homes were thinking how did
that come about and what's been the
response well I so actually when we when
you set out to do this um we started the
film first so i bought the land and I
was still in grad school actually and
finishing my masters in it like this
accelerated program so basically I had
no time to start the house until I
started wrapping that up but we did have
items on spring break and we decided to
go to San Francisco just on just for a
visit basically see some friends and
that was that's where Jay schaeffer's
from and so kind of on a lark I had sent
an email to tumbleweed and said hey can
we get an interview with you we're gonna
make this documentary about tiny houses
and you know he said he would and so all
of a sudden we were doing it in and so
we actually a shot probably three or
four interviews before ever starting the
house and I think one interesting thing
is that one of the things that's made us
sort of able to take on this project you
know being are the first film that both
of us have worked on you know as our own
project is that the the people in the
tiny house community have been so
encouraging from the beginning I mean I
remember when we went to interview Jay
Shaffer you know he was the first
interview that we did we hadn't done any
other filming and we kind of showed up
with our DSLR camera and it's funny
because um there was a reporter from The
New Yorker who is there the same day
interviewing him and I remember just
thinking I mean the fact that we were
these you know two kids you'd called
like email dress well like these you
know these two people who you know had
like emailed him out of nowhere and uh
you know I probably didn't seem like
super professional you know and he has
this new yorker reporter just the fact
that he had made time for us you know
not you know we didn't have a ton of
credit
I guess is what I mean you know behind
us when we contacted him and and i think
you know from the beginning people have
treated us you know in a way that has
made us wanting to move forward and tell
this story and i think that you know
we've learned a lot in the last year and
a half and i think that now you know
where we have a lot to show you know and
we're pretty professional and things
like that but um you know but just the
fact that from the get-go we were sort
of treated as documentary filmmakers i
think made it um you know more of an
impetus to actually actually make the
film yeah yeah people have been really
generous with their time and we've
actually in the early days I think it
was a bit of a challenge to track down
people for the film in in that we we
were looking for a certain type of
people to show in the film mostly
because you know as far as the message
you know we've we've we've seen
hostility towards the tiny house
movement from people who aren't that
familiar with it on in terms of comments
on blogs and things like that and so we
thought that if for this message the
best way the most likely way that people
would be susceptible to hearing it would
be if we profile people that were
relatively normal you know appearing and
sort of you know so people could picture
themselves living in a house similar to
you know as these people did so we were
so so basically we're trying to find
different types of people that were also
not you know so far into the fringe that
people couldn't relate to them we wanted
the characters in the film to be
relatable into and to be people that
would you would be friends with and if
stuff so and then there's also you know
the small house world there's a lot
people who don't it's kind of quasi
illegal so they don't really want to be
interviewed or they don't want to
advertise that they're doing this and so
you know then it's been great but it's
there's limitations too so
you